what we hoped to accomplish on Deepwater
Horizon was to give the audience a sense
of being out there on that rig of
traveling to a place where we all know a
great disaster occurred the IMAX screen
allows the audience to have an
experience where they're literally
almost falling into the frame
sound really encompasses dialogue music
which adds rhythm which adds pulse which
adds intensity and then sound effects
which really give the audience a sense
that they're in this reality trapped or
emotionally swept away with with the
story the job of the sound designer is
to fill out the theater beyond the
limits of the frame and give the
audience a sense of being immersed in
this experience the sound part of IMAX
is extraordinary
they've taken full range speakers out
into the theatre and allowed the
audience to sort of hear things in a
much more natural way we're able through
sound to both give pause which is
important because the most dramatic
elements occur after a pause and working
from silence you're able to use the
entire dynamic range of the theatre to
just deliver to the audience something
really shocking really dramatic really
powerful
good job the visual frame is on the
screen it's in the front of the
auditorium it's bound by the edges that
the cinematographer has prescribed to
that particular shot sound lives in the
ether it's it's dispersed in the theater
it doesn't live in real time the way
picture does sound is just a vibration
in the room sound is just a momentary
thing that can't be frozen in time when
you go to an IMAX theater you're looking
at and listening to what the filmmakers
intended you to look at listen to and
experience